I'm delighted to have as my guest today Mr Anthony Lewis who has been head of the
London bureau of The New York Times since December nine hundred sixty
four previously Mr Lewis reporter for the Washington
bureau where he won a Pulitzer Prize for his coverage of the Supreme Court. He has
written a book entitled Gideon's trumpet about a great case in the Supreme Court
and most recently a book about the struggle for civil rights entitled portrait of
a decade.
Mr Lewis you've written a great deal about the impact of the law on American
society does the law apply you similarly active role in
England not a top. That's one of the disappointing things to me I guess that I care so much about the
law in the law in this country is.
A much more marginal affair for historic reasons
that lawyers and judges just do not want to involve themselves in the kind of social
moral political questions that American judges and particularly the Supreme Court
just naturally deals with it's unthinkable in this country that judges would take it on
themselves to decide on national
policy on racial discrimination not say or. More
recent subject subject that judges
would ensure the fairness of political district
ing for election of Representatives those subjects are for historical
reasons have been put aside for Parliament to decide and it's just tradition if you try
to bring a case with that kind of Marler
political overtone a case in which judges are asked to pass on a basic social question.
They will say we're sorry take that to
Parliament with the actually have the power to pass judgment. They just
decide not to don't they have the power it so
well of course judges can always do anything they want the question is whether they'll be overruled and the answer is they would
be overruled and that's so in a sense they don't have the power.
What's happened is the interplay of the courts in Parliament. The courts discovered that when
they did things parliament quickly overrule them and Parliament in this country has the ultimate
power unlike the United States where the court speaks with the voice of the Constitution. There is no
written constitution
here. So whatever the court says Parliament can undo the next day just as it wishes by a
simple vote. The judges have perhaps out of a sense of
self-preservation made a point of not doing things that
they thought parliament would change.
Partly this comes out of a period when courts were very
conservative and when for example they did things that restricted the rights of
trade unions to strike and to demonstrate and do other things they want to do this was just at the
time when the Labor Party was being formed in this country was
emerging and the actions of the courts were much resented and legislation was passed
on do what the courts had
said.
And that left a permanent mark court's just Although now
on the
whole anything the courts did in the way of what we would regard as social questions would be on
the progressive side because the law's so backward in this country and all sorts of questions
that that any change would be you know really on the progressive side and
yet the hangover of distrust for courts and judges prevents any action at
all can you give a specific when you say the law is so backward in so many ways.
What would be an example of
this or there was a case just
handed down. In which
the Court of Appeal held in line with
precedence or quite old that a barrister barristers
the branch of the legal
profession a member of the branch of the lever fashion that appears in
court sees a courtroom lawyer wears a wig. And
again the barrister could not be sued for
negligence this is it has lots
of reasons most people think it's a. Heard you can sue anybody else for negligence you consider a doctor
who conducts a bad operation you can sue an accountant who cooks your books you can't sue a lawyer
who mangles your
case why because some judge said that a couple hundred years ago in the court of appeals said well you
know we don't want to change now there's an immense respect for precedent much more than
in the United States and a kind of frozen condition of the law as a result.
On the theory in my view as an American
I have to add to be fair and completely erroneous there e that
parliament will correct the flaws that if the law's out of date that parliament will bring it
up today that it by I say is phony because Parliament doesn't have time to worry about the
law Parliament's time is completely film sets. Day and
night doing the political things that Mr Wilson wants to get
through it rarely devotes any attention to the law at all.
What is it true that until just recently the court could not even
reverse its own decisions from centuries gone by that it
only recently has the power to change its mind.
The House of Lords which is one of the peculiar institutions in this country in which that's partly
as a legislative body body but also sets as the highest court of Britain.
Although it's I interjected all oh it's called the House of Lords all members of the House of Lords
do not in practice sit as judges but only a half dozen people appointed
Lords specifically to be judges until last year
the House of Lords took the view that it could never change its mind. IT'S IT'S IT'S ALMOST
KILLED Bertie and it's so
fantastic some majority fifty or a hundred years ago decided some point which
now the judges would readily admit was perfectly absurd and yet they
say we can't change our mind once we've said that black is white it must always be white.
Well it's year quite to everybody surprise and it is perhaps a hopeful sign the court in all it's not.
Just say a gnat's that was no longer true and that from now on when they thought a prior
decision was erroneous they would feel free to overrule it.
I may add as a sign of the conservatism of the profession in this country not just of the
judges but much more significantly of the legal
profession that when that announcement was made the chairman of the Bar Council or
the secretary in any case one of the figures on the Bar Council issued a statement saying that
he questioned whether the court had the power to change its mind about changing
its mind without being authorized to do so by parliament they are very cautious and
days as this Jane had any effect in the news as it borne any
fruit so
far none whatsoever they have not actually overruled any prior case yet and it's clear that at
least the beginning they're going
to do so very seldom because as I say lawyers are very
conservative Parliament is very sensitive of its power and of the House of Lords began overruling
cases wholesale there'd be a lot of noses out of
joint in June one thousand nine hundred eighty five the government passed a law
Commission Act which was to study and reform the law. Have there been
any results benefits results from
this and there have been some preliminary results of course it's too soon to expect very
much the Law Commission Act and the whole idea
of law reform indicates that again the conservatism of the profession.
The act was an answer to the very process of stultification of which I have spoken
the fact that over the centuries regard for precedent has been so
strong that old irrelevant decisions have been allowed to accumulate unnoticed and
no changes made
in Lord Gardner When he was who is now Lord Chancellor when he
was a private lawyer campaign for law reform through a commission and
he won money but when Labor came into power he was made Lord Chancellor and he pushed through the Law
Commission Act Now there are these commissions that can propose reforms in the law changes in the
law. Which come before Parliament but in a rather routine way so
that it doesn't take a lot
of time which is the precious commodity in parliament but and here's the but it's a good idea I'm all
for it I think it's fine and overdue but the view of the legal
profession is that lease. But the law commissions in various The Law
Commission and its committees in various
fields can really only deal with what would we call lawyers law technical
points of procedure.
Does this also mean then that the findings of psychology and sociology
and kind of disciplines are beginning to influence judge
legal judgments in the states have no bearing on the
legal tradition here.
No is an awfully strong word but if there's any bearing it's invisible to the naked eye let's put it
that way I will add that not only are there very seldom any references to
the disciplines you've just mentioned but under the practice in British
courts in this is to me one of the most remarkable things when
a British court passes on the meaning of a statute passed by parliament.
Now the statute is passed and
it usually has like American statutes is written rather barely And it's kind of hard to tell what the
words mean when it's applied to a specific
case. British courts are forbidden to look into the debates of
Parliament to try to find out what the words may mean there they are not allowed to
use legislative history which is of course the absolute most basic thing that every American court
does to find out the meaning of the statute because that would give the courts in their
view too much freeplay they must only look at the printed words of the
statute book. There seems to be more and more concern about this
expressed Do you think there is a prospect of change in the near
future five or ten you change in the legal profession.
I would almost say ask Charles Dickens I mean he has. Yes I think there is some.
Change government coming there are rumblings but it is still
an intensely conservative profession I think if it's going to be
changed probably wholesale I mean radical
reform such as the amalgamation of the two branches of the profession solicitors and barristers into one profession
as we have it which would be a real impulse for a change of attitude in the profession
more
modern that kind of thing I think can only come not from the lawyers and selves. But can
only come from perhaps an outside Royal Commission which would investigate and propose
the Economist the very good Weekly magazine has proposed a royal
commission with a large element of non lawyers for that very reason.
Could you explain the difference between solicitors and
barristers solicitors are the office lawyers just sort of
ordinary chaps who sit in their office and when you have a problem you go to a solicitor.
They helped draft your contract or you will
or somebody sues you you go to a solicitor and you talk to him
then there are these elevated people socially as well
as in other ways elevated by tradition barristers barristers
are as I say regarded as rather high falutin solicitors
or grubby chaps who sit in an office barristers who wear wigs and gowns
and appear in court.
There are only two thousand of them there are very small clubby group in England and they practically all
know each other.
When you have something you have to go into court. Your solicitor. Goes to
a barrister The mere client is not ever allowed to approach this exalted
figure your solicitor must choose a barrister and ask him whether he plays would be kind enough
to take your case in
the court. You stated restated that the law is is
extremely conservative here. The whole legal profession. What do you think the reasons are for this.
Perhaps it's partly the division in the profession. The fact that the trends have always
been set by the barristers because of. Because everyone regards them as
they leave. Figures these elevated types as I say and because at least
until recently they have by definition of had to be rich upper class
people and that was because you didn't earn
anything as a barrister you literally are not a penny for five or six years after you began
practicing you just went into court and watched other people and you never got a brief yourself so
you couldn't do it unless you came in with a lot of money.
Now they have legal aid that is the state provides lawyers for poor people
in both civil and criminal cases a lot of those legal aid breaks are going to young
barrister so that you can make a kind of bare living at the beginning. Perhaps that will be a change
to bring some lower class less establishment figures
in the main reason however I think is the system of legal education which is
again amazing.
You don't have to have gone to college at all to be a lawyer in Britain
much less law school I don't have graduate law schools.
AT ALL You may go to a university if you do you will get
some special legal training as an
undergraduate but mainly you come to London and you eat dinners. You literally you go
to an in one of the legal ends of the temple and you sit in a great hall
and you eat dinners where you're supposed to imbibe a lot bias talking to
your to your elders and you're tutored in specific subjects
for example you have a tutor on contracts who could tell you what the law of
contracts was at some length and then you pass an exam and if you can pass your exam
and contracts in the
subject and have eaten the requisite number of dinners which is very important you. I mean
that when you're called to the bar.
Well the difficulty with that is that it wholly omits the searching
mind open opening quality of an American law school where instead of just being told what the law
of contracts is you spend your time debating the rightness or wrongness of judicial
decisions the case method then you find out there isn't exactly a right or
wrong it's a process it's a way of. Thinking and American law schools at
least good ones and there are quite a few good ones really do shake you up
at their best not that American lawyers are conservative many of them
are but it is a much more open minded profession I think than here partly
because people have come from this closed system of legal education with
no sense of challenge in an American law school a student is expected to
side of the professor I think you're all wrong I think that judge was just crazy and I've never seen a worse
decision in my life. That's just not on the cards
here Mr Lewis you deserve very closely both the American and
English democracies at work and I wonder what you feel are the the most significant
differences between the two systems.
But it's a paradoxical difference I think.
In this country the House of Commons by tradition and practice
is the focus of very much that goes on public statements are always made by
the prime minister or other ministers in the House of Commons Not always but almost always important
public statements they don't have press
conferences big events happen in the House of Commons. There
is no sense of the separation of the presidency that we have in which
the real focus in Washington is on Lyndon B. Johnson and Congress is just something
else but the paradox is that the House of Commons in this country has no power and
Congress has lots of
power relatively speaking. And you can examine that
in terms that say of Senator
Fulbright who can hold a committee hearing. Not that he can really push a button and make the
bomb go off and have power in that sense but he can bother the president an awful lot. He can
hold a committee hearing can call Secretary McNamara Secretary Rusk.
Put propositions to them make them defend their Vietnam
policy a separate political personalities can arise in
Congress like Robert Kennedy say in the Senate arise and have a
political dimension all. Zone apart from the government or the official opposition those
things don't happen in this country House of Commons has
no committees that can could has one or two committees of a minor character has no committees that have
the power to call anybody from the government nobody from the government ever appears before a committee and that
become
common the foreign secretary never is asked a
question by a committee to defend his policy he is asked the substitute is
this process of Question
Time in the House of Commons which is infrequent brief uninformed not the
it can't be that only fifteen minutes you know that kind of thing and the questions have to be put down weeks ahead.
There isn't this real process in a committee room of having the questions that are
that day's questions pressed on relentlessly
of secretary of defense saying.
And because of the party system in this country. The fact
that you must vote with your party that you don't have the freedom that you do as a senator or congressman really
to vote as you
will the government has an absolute whip hand the government says we
have a bill here it is it's going to pass and it does pass government has a majority
of ninety five now any billet it puts up is going to pass this just no
question about
it literally this is like a rubber stamp it is like a rubber stamp the
Commons does provide a forum that's very interesting but when the when the issue
comes to a head a government is always going to prevail and it's going to prevail short of some
catastrophe I mean if the pound falls.
If something like that happens then presumably the whole party system may break down and fifty members
of the Labor Party may say we don't like Harold Wilson and we just can't stand it anymore we're going
to get out of the Labor Party but the price is getting out of the Labor Party because if you don't
vote with him and you do that persistently you're
out where does any significant debate take place if there is such
a that's a very interesting question because. It takes place within the
government within the cabinet particularly. And here again it is much
more concealed from view than in the United States because the press is a
supine figure in this country.
Reporters for reasons I don't fully understand just hardly ever dig behind the
facade the government puts up and you very rarely have any sense of
the controversy within government about policy which you often do in the United States and
for example you know
American newspapers reported odd nauseum that George Ball when he
was undersecretary of state took a different view from the secretary on Vietnam and on Europe and
those issues were fully
explored. Nobody in this country would ever dream of reporting that somebody within
the government took a different view from someone else. I put that to strongly. Yes they do occasionally
reported but it's the unusual thing the debates take place all behind closed
doors to give a dramatic
example you know tax proposals in the United States particularly for radical reforms
and tax
law are proposed by the president or the secretary of the Treasury they
have lengthy hearings I mean months often in the House Ways and Means Committee public
hearings people testified.
Long debate passes the House debate in the Senate Finance Committee debate
on the floor of the Senate. Back and forth with Treasury Representatives finally it passes or it doesn't
pass in this country. The chancellor puts down a budget. There are no hints
before it's a regarded as the world's greatest violation of secrecy indeed grounds for
for being thrown out of the government as has actually happened if there's any link on what
policy he's considering which of course they would be in the United States over months they'd be say well we
have this tax for that
tax. He puts down his budget the same day
with about an hour's debate the House of Commons by a party line
vote writes the tax into law and it becomes
it's collectible as of that
date then they go on and have a further long debate about making a permanent part of law.
Where the government majority of ninety five Of course it always will be passed in the end but there are no
committee hearings.
No member of the public ever testifies etc It's
amazing what you do it is a great deal of talk in England about reforming the parliament.
What do you think will be the substance and results of this.
I'm a bit cynical on that to if I were Prime Minister I wouldn't want to change it and I don't
think any prime minister when he's in office no matter how much he's talked about reform when he was in opposition
is actually going to do anything very
radical Now it's true that there is a reformist leader of the House of Commons now
Richard Crossman and he will doubtless do some things I think one thing they may do is
to introduce television cameras which would be interesting I think on the whole I'd be for that
when members of the
public see how much time Parliament Rice on schoolboy jokes that might change.
I think that would be healthy although I'd hate to lose the schoolboy jokes altogether.
But the really radical change would be the creation of committees with power
to call ministers before them and power to ask them questions and require answers and
I'm skeptical that that will ever happen.
Many people at home look to him and as an example that we should
emulate in terms of social social welfare social
legislation national health plan economy. What do you feel we have
to learn from
England but I wouldn't think if I may say so with great love of this country which
I
have I do love Britain. I wouldn't think the planned economy was something that.
Showed any signs of needing emulation at the moment when you see the state of the British economy
unemployment increasing investment down really a very bad way. I
think there is something to be learned learn from the social
side which we have begun to learn with the Medicare program I personally
find the National Health Service a very desirable thing I
think it has faults doctors are under.
Hey there aren't enough hospitals. Those are the four false of lack of resources this
country just doesn't have the resources that the United States has doesn't have the money.
But in terms of equity and convenience and fairness I think the National Health
Service works extremely well I go to a doctor I don't make an
appointment ahead. I go to the surgery as I call it. If I'm
sick and I wait if there are other people but I on the
whole find that I wait. Not more but less than I did when I had an appointment with a doctor in the
United States because appointments for the
mythical you go in you're treated in turn a very fair
good system and no charge of cost of course just the the charge
that you pay as a regular social costs like Social Security and doctors come to your
home also. I may add which is
unusual in the United States or the other other areas because National Health is the one
that has heard of most of the other areas that you feel are
then relation to United States social areas.
Well I I don't know I think the British would say yes as to for
example housing. I have my doubts all of Britain has a
very government subsidized a highly
subsidized housing program which the government builds houses and rents them for much less money than
they cost.
I myself am in doubt that in the end that produces social good because the
result of that has been to not build enough houses. It's true that in the United
States we have an inadequate number of houses built for poor or
middle class
people but on the whole I think that
the depressing effect on actual construction is self defeating
the necessity of always building things at at a cost which you don't recover
the result of that is because of the lack of resources in the government that you just don't build
houses. So you know I'm I'm I'm not terribly in through. He
asked
about other aspects of the social system that may be just a lack of resources
and I'm speaking of there are good kindergartens there are good provisions for daycare.
There are good things caring for children I think on the whole of that at least.
The bigger cities of the United States have done the same sorts of
things. To lose we've been talking a good deal about
what's wrong with various parts of English law and government.
What how is the quality of life in London or is it a depressing is
as the content of our conversation isn't up to them.
I'm afraid I've been somewhat misleading in that respect. You've asked me questions on
subjects about which I'm
critical but the fact is that the quality of life here is very good and maybe the
lesson of it is that things that bumble along aren't very effective
may not always be so bad I'm I'm reminded of American friend of mine who lives in
this in the square in
Chelsea and he was interviewed by somebody in a British
magazine what do you think about British life and he railed on about how inefficient it was and how they had to
tone up and get moving and so
on and then he looked out of the window of his house and he said Look at that square look at all that park
in the middle that wasted space in all those low
houses. This is not shocking said I'll tell you the day that they fell it all up
with skyscrapers I'm leaving. And that's the thing about life here the
paces is slower. The landscape that is this the City of
London
has much more contemplate of air low buildings parks
and not with the jam and dirt and noise of New York and I may say
that I prefer it very much.
Last summer. You wrote a piece in The New York Times about physiology in Britain. You
said the atmosphere London today can be almost eerie in its quality relentless
for volatile. Do you stand by that because it causes enormous controversy when you wrote this.
Do you still think this is
true I think I stand by it at the time I was feeling
very strongly the a sense of separation between two things one was
the surface pleasures of London which are very great because the theatre
and music and dance and people close are they
really wonderful and very gay. And I didn't mean to disapprove Marley I thought they
were wonderful but I meant by. The airiness of
it was that underneath I thought the country was heading for
economic disaster Well it was five weeks after I wrote that piece that the economic crisis came on
and we began the squeeze in the phrase and all these other things.
So I don't think on the whole I was wrong. What
I wish was that there was some way to translate. These wonderful qualities of living the gay a day
the creativity the imagination and the
youth because the youngness of life here is terribly important young people have a much more
important role and they do in the United States in newspapers and magazines in the arts
in theatre and so on some way to translate
that. Drive into the economic side on
the political side and give Britain the kind of leadership I think she needs.
Do you see any signs that you know months later the disses happening.
No thank you Mr
Lewis you've been listening to Mr Anthony Lewis the putative Prize winning
journalist who's been head of the New York Times bureau in London since December nine
hundred sixty four. Thank you and good bye for now.